is it true um that the woman who
designed this is keano Reeves's mom yes
she did a lot of sewing for me she did a
lot of my clothes but I remember Kiana
when he was just little and she would
bring him over to my house when we were
feding or when I would go to the shop
where she worked so and one day years
and years and years ago I was at doing a
show somewhere and somebody knocked on
the door and of course Keana was already
famous at the time he knocked on the
door and he said do you remember me I'm
the little boy that used to sit at your
feet when my mom was doing I said oh my
god of course I knew he was you know had
become a strawberry it had it didn't
connect to me that that was who that was
and I heard that he wore it actually for
Halloween one year oh he did he wore
this exact outfit and he said it's his
favorite Halloween costume he's ever
worn I would love to see ke he's great
he's the sweetest Guy this is the most
interesting flattering silhouette I love
the bunny suit I think it's the coolest
I do too and when my husband and I have
been married uh 50 years I his birthday
and I thought I'm going to go in and
take Carl his breakfast in my bunny suit
and uh so I did you did and I yeah this
actually this was just two or three
years ago what did Carl say bir day oh
he loved it yeah he that's the best
breakfast I think he ever
[Music]
had